with the rebound and  they got some time two seconds to go  giannis it'll count  they got the bucket with point four to  go in the first half  richard just doing work mark 18.6  boards giannis slams it home  man he extended that left arm just watch  this drive  i mean look at that how easy it is for  him with the left hand  one more look one dribble multiple guys  [Laughter]  he's down to 15 and giannis just  waltzing from vogel commented to me that  the lakers need anthony davis to make  threes it helps their spacing  but you know kentavious oh my gosh  say it with your chest giannis 24 points  18  boards and he is a terror coming at you  [Applause]  good night  that is a wonderful  giannis has a mismatch but they're going  to wall him off not  fast enough though wow he makes quick  work of it  little ball fake